SCOTT ELLIS: Hi.
Welcome to our
talk on how to take
charge of your sensitive data.
My name is Scott Ellis,
and I'm a Product Manager
on Google Cloud's Data
Security and Privacy team.
Now, data powers your
business, and data
is one of your greatest assets.
But it can also be one
of your biggest risks.
And today we're going
to talk about how you
can take charge of your data.
And we're going to
cover topics like how
you can discover and
classify your sensitive data.
We feel that understanding
your sensitive data
is the first step
in protecting it.
And once you have that
kind of visibility,
we're going to talk about
how you can manage your data
risk using things
like security policy,
confidential processing,
and data obfuscation.
And ultimately, we want to
be able to do this at scale
so that you can focus
on your business
and, again, really
focus on the outcomes.
Now, to do this,
automation is key.
And again, if you want
to know your data,
and if want to understand your
sensitive data so that you
can better protect it, on-demand
scans and manual review
can help.
However, the challenge is
that your data is growing
as your business is growing.
And that means your data
footprint is growing,
and it's more
challenging to manage it.
And so you really need a way
to automatically discover
and classify your data.
And today we're going
to talk about how
you can get automatic
discovery, automatic inspection,
automatic classification, and
automatic data profiling--
really, automatic DLP.
And this is now
available for BigQuery,
and it's powered by
our Cloud DLP platform.
And what that means
is that you can
get an understanding
of your data risk
across your entire
BigQuery footprint.
And that means
you can understand
where you have, maybe,
low-risk data, which
could mean that there's no
evidence of sensitive data
or that it's got extra
protections in place,
or where you have
moderate or high risk.
This could be where you have
evidence of sensitive data,
like PII, or evidence
of unstructured data
or free text that might
be inside of your tables,
or where you have highly
sensitive data, something
like PII, like credit card
numbers, or financial data.
And what automatic DLP will
do is generate rich insights
for each table and
column across your org.
And that's really
important, because you
want to get that visibility
across all of your tables, all
of your columns,
so you can really
understand your data risk.
Now, here's an example
of a column profile
for a table where we're seeing
different types of metrics
that indicate the type of
risk, the type of sensitivity.
And it includes the
DLP's predicted infoType.
And this gives an
indication in this table
that we see evidence of
a credit card number,
an email address, and a
couple of columns that
have evidence of a person name.
This kind of data
type can really
help you understand your
data or take the next step
to protecting it.
Now, this automatic
visibility with DLP
really means that you get
continuous monitoring.
That means that tables are
picked up automatically.
So as you're creating
new projects,
new data sets, and new tables
in BigQuery, Automatic DLP
will pick them up automatically
and profile them for you.
And it's designed as a
fully managed service
to have low overhead.
What that means is
that there's no jobs
to manage or orchestrate, and
you can enable this directly
in the Cloud Console.
It's also been built with
data residency in mind.
And again, if you're turning
on across your entire org,
you may have data in
different regions,
different geographic regions.
And DLP will inspect that
data in the geographic region
that you have set for
your BigQuery tables.
It will also
generate the profiles
and store them in that
same geographic region.
And that way, you can ensure
that your data stays where
you want it, even when it's
being inspected and profiled
by DLP.
And lastly, this
is Google-driven.
And what that means
is that we figure out
how to inspect and
profile your data,
so you can focus,
again, on the outcomes.
Great.
Now, let's see this in action.
And now let's see a demo
of this automatic DLP.
And for this, let's meet Angie.
Angie is a data
compliance officer
for a large online
retailer that serves
customers across the globe.
Angie oversees how data is
collected, shared, and used
across all departments.
Angie's company is
growing, and their data
is growing with them.
They've chosen to use BigQuery
as their data warehouse
to power most of their
analytics and business needs.
And usage of BigQuery is spread
across several departments
and project teams.
And again, these teams are
creating new projects, new data
sets, new tables constantly
as part of their business.
And Angie wants
to know, how can I
gain visibility into the
sensitive data across my org?
And for this, we're going
to use our Automatic DLP.
What this means is,
you can now enable
Cloud DLP across your org and
your entire BigQuery footprint.
So what that means is
that you can turn DLP
on across your
organization, as we're
seeing here, across specific
organization folders--
maybe these represent
departments or different parts
of your organization--
or individual projects.
Now, BigQuery data lives inside
tables and data sets that
reside inside these projects.
So depending on where
you turn this on,
you'll get coverage
across all that data.
When this is enabled, Cloud
DLP will automatically
pick up new data,
pick up existing data,
profile it, and give
you those insights
into your sensitive data.
Now, enabling this is easy
and can be done completely
in the Cloud Console UI.
For this, at the
org level, Angie
would navigate to Security
and then Data Loss Prevention
and then click on the
Scan Org link here.
Now, let's go ahead and
see what that looks like.
I'm going to switch over
here to my test project.
We're going to click
on Scan Organization.
Now, we can configure
this in one click and take
care of everything for you.
But let's go ahead and
walk through the custom
configuration, just so you can
see the options that you have.
The first option
you have here is
to choose whether you want to
scan your entire organization,
or if you want to
browse and select
individual folders to scan.
For now, we'll just scan
our entire organization.
Now, this service is
built with Cloud Data Loss
Prevention, or Cloud DLP.
So you can use your existing
inspection templates,
or you can create a new one.
But this is powered by the
same infoType detectors
that we have for Cloud DLP.
So you can select from
our built-in detectors
or define custom
ones of your own.
Additionally, you can
select the third option,
which will run a set of our
most popular default detectors.
And just simply
select that option.
And next, you can
see the permissions
needed to run this scan.
Now, we're very transparent
about the permissions
that are needed here.
We can also create
those for you,
or you can set those permissions
individually-- again, just
depending on what is best
for your organization.
And next, let's talk a little
bit about data residency.
So data residency is
crucial to your data.
And we've built this Cloud
DLP from the ground up
to support data residency.
And that holds true for
this automatic solution
for BigQuery.
What that means is
that when you have
data in a certain
geographic region,
configured in BigQuery to be
in a certain geographic region,
DLP will scan data
in that same region.
So the process of
scanning your data
happens in the same
geographic region.
Additionally, the
profile output will
be stored in the same geographic
region as your BigQuery data.
And again, this allows you to
maintain that data residency.
Additionally, we
give you the control
to decide where to store
the actual configuration
data, which is what
we're configuring here.
Again, we want to make
sure you have good insight
and control of your data
to know where and how it's
being processed.
Now, if I click
Create here, this
is going to enable
this new service
for my entire organization,
which is great.
However, I've already done that.
So I'm going to go
ahead and click Cancel.
And let's take a look at
what the results look like.
Now, in this particular
organization,
I only have these
six projects here.
And each of these projects
has BigQuery data, data sets,
and tables inside them.
Now, here at the
Project view, I'm
just getting a high-level
view of the tables
and a summary of the risk
and sensitivity in them.
Let's go ahead and click
on one of these projects.
And now what I'm seeing is
every data set and table that
is in that project and the
associated metrics at the table
level, including things like
our data risk assessments,
whether this data is public,
what kind of encryption it has,
row count.
And I can also click
on one of these tables
to go even further.
I'm going to click
on this table,
and this will take me into
the column-level profile.
Here we see detailed metrics
for every column in that table,
including DLP's predicted
info type, which,
again is-- if we can
figure out this column
looks like a
particular data type,
we actually label that
column here with that type.
So here we're seeing a column
with credit card numbers, email
addresses, and person name.
It looks like we have a
first name and a last name,
as well as metrics
around that for data risk
sensitivity and some
additional metrics
around whether or
not this column looks
like it has free text, or
it's unstructured, maybe
a comment field, as
well as uniqueness
and null-percent estimates.
Now, these are important,
because imagine this column
of credit card numbers--
we also see that there is
a uniqueness score of 1.
And that's a high
uniqueness score,
which indicates that this column
likely contains unique credit
card numbers in every
row, which would
be different than a low
uniqueness score, where
maybe that same
value was repeated
over and over multiple times.
We also see that with an
estimated null percent of 0%.
That means that this column
looks like it's pretty well
populated, and there's not a lot
of null or sparsely populated
data in these columns.
But again, this is the
kind of rich insights
that you get with the
column-level profile,
as well as the table- and
project-level profiles.
And all of this, again,
will be continuously
running and generating
as new tables are
created across your org.
Great.
Let's go back to Angie.
Now, Angie needed an
automated solution.
And Angie chose to use
Cloud DLP's new service
to automatically discover,
inspect, and profile
their BigQuery tables for
sensitive data like PII.
And this automatic DLP service
will pick up new projects,
data sets, and
tables automatically.
And the outcome is that Angie's
team now has clear visibility
into their sensitive
data and can
make more informed decisions
about how it's protected,
used, processed, and shared.
And that concludes our demo
of the new automatic DLP
for BigQuery.
Great.
We've now just shown you how
you can get org-wide visibility
with the new automatic DLP.
And again, this can give
you clear visibility
into your sensitive
data so that you can
make more informed decisions.
And that's now
available for BigQuery.
Now that you have that clear
visibility into your data,
let's figure out some ways
to manage your data risk
and reduce your data risk.
So first, how can I enable
more fine-grained access
control and protection?
So now that you know where
your sensitive data is,
maybe you want to go in and
employ column-level access
policy.
And using BigQuery
policy tags, you
can enable column-level
access enforcement,
which can help you strike
a balance between access
and security.
So an example policy
is shown here.
And these policies have
a taxonomy or a hierarchy
to them.
What that means is that we can
put an element like credit card
number underneath or inside
of a higher-level policy
like financial.
And that allows you to grant
access and manage your policy
at that higher
level, while enabling
you to tag the data at the lower
level, at credit card number.
Let's see this in action.
So here's an example
here where we're
seeing a table where we have
tagged four of the columns
in here with a tag for person
name, email address, and credit
card number.
And we have turned
on enforcement
of a policy using
BigQuery policy tags,
so that users can only access
those sensitive elements
if they have the
right permission.
And what that means is, if
I have access to this table,
but I don't have access to
those particular columns,
I'll still be able to query
the table and, in this case,
maybe run analysis
on the payment type
and the transaction amount.
But I won't be able to
access the sensitive elements
like the PII here that
we see unless I have
that additional access control.
And again that's
the way you can find
that balance between
access and security
and, overall, reduce and
manage some of your data risk.
Another technique is to go in
and use obfuscation or masking.
And this is something that
you can do with Cloud DLP,
and it's a technique we
call de-identification.
Now, de-identification
includes a set of transforms
like redaction,
masking, tokenization,
format-preserving encryption,
date shifting, bucketing,
and more.
And these transformations
are designed
to actually manipulate
and transform your data
in order to reduce the risk.
So for example, in this
before-and-after animation that
we're seeing, we're seeing these
techniques applied to a table--
in this case, a table
that has four columns.
And we're applying
transformations
across the entire column in
these first three columns.
Again, our goal here is to
reduce the risk of the data.
So we are manipulating
and transforming
the sensitive information
and replacing it
with something
that is obfuscated.
Now, in that fourth
column, we're
combining the power of
DLP's inspection capability
with the masking so
that we can actually
go into these unstructured
comment fields,
find the sensitive
element, and only mask
that sensitive element.
And this is something
that you can
do because we've
combined that inspection
capability with the data-masking
capability all in one platform.
Otherwise, you'd have
to potentially redact
the entire Comment Field column.
But instead, you
can actually go in
and redact only the sensitive
information in line.
Now, another question
is, how can I
improve protection
and process my data
in a confidential manner?
Again, now that
you have visibility
into where your
sensitive data exists,
you can use
confidential processing
to process that more securely.
An example of that would
be Confidential Dataproc,
which offers encryption
in use, which can easily
add security protections to your
most sensitive data workloads.
Here's an example where we are
turning on confidential compute
with a simple command-line
flag as we create and launch
our Dataproc pipeline.
Now, Confidential
Dataproc is now in GA.
Now, Dataproc is a fully
managed and highly scalable
service for running things
like Apache Spark, Flink,
and Presto.
And Confidential Dataproc adds
that data encryption in use,
again, to protect your
most sensitive data.
And it does this by using
confidential VMs to provide
that in-line memory encryption.
And this is powered by AMD's
secure encrypted virtualization
processors.
And this brings us to the end
of our talk on how to take
charge of your sensitive data.
And we'll leave you with a few
key takeaways and action items.
First, automatic DLP is
now available for BigQuery
and can give you insight
into your entire BigQuery
footprint across your org.
You can get started in the
Cloud Console by navigating
to Security and then
Data Loss Prevention,
or you can read
our documentation
at cloud.google.com/dlp.
You can also check out
obfuscation and masking,
or what we call
de-identification,
also at cloud.google.com/dlp.
And you can read more about
confidential processing,
which is available
with VMs, GKE,
and now in GA for Dataproc at
cloud.google.com/confidential
computing.
Thank you again for
joining us today,
and we're happy to be
part of your journey
as you take care of
your sensitive data.
Thank you.